herzlich willkommen in düsseldorf besser
gesagt in little tokyo und das klingt
vielleicht ein bisschen komisch aber es
ist wirklich so wir sind hier in der
einzigen japan town in deutschland und
dem größten zentrum für japanisches
leben in europa warum ist das so hier
entlang der immermannstraße deshalb ist
ja auch dieses schild oben haben sich
einige große japanische firmen
niedergelassen die auch das japanische
leben mit sich gebracht haben und so ist
es geschehen dass hier wirklich
japanische kultur restaurant kultur aber
auch supermärkte erlebbar geworden sind
und für mich als fußgänger als food
liebhaber ist das ultra ich hab das gar
nicht auf dem schirm ist mir ein freund
das gesagt hat und jetzt bin ich hier
und werde den ganzen tag japanische zu
essen setzten viel spaß da nicht so wir
sind relativ früh hier gestartet und
deshalb muss sie erstmal ne kleinigkeit
frühstücken und das besondere ist ich
bin wirklich eigentlich ein
unbeschriebenes blatt was japanische
küche angeht also ich kenne so die
absoluten klassiker sowieso warmen aber
hab das auch noch nie so in reinform
gegessen und was ihr aber kenne aus dem
internet sind japanische backwaren und
die wollen wir uns jetzt
weißt du das
[Musik]
wir haben 53 spezialitäten secured
dieses band mit roten bohnen eine
currywurst rolle und ein schoko hörnchen
das probieren wert legen corona durfte
man sich darin leider nicht hinsetzen
aber wir haben hier unsere spezialitäten
ich packe die erste auswahl hielt sich
schon sehr crazy an wir haben hier ein
schoko hörnchen man sieht das ist
relativ dick gefüllt und es ist ultras
quatsche ich
hatte gedacht das sei mehr so was wie
nutella es ist aber eher wie so ein
schokopudding next up das traditionelle
japanische frühstücks wir haben
obendrauf mohn und innen ist das ganze
gefühl mit einer rote bohnen passte ich
finde es einfach so geil dass man sowas
hier erleben kann probieren wir
wow ganz außergewöhnlich der mond
superlecker obendrauf ist glaube ich
nicht mal ein neues lieblings frühstück
aber trotzdem ne geile erfahrung
currywurst röllchen ich weiß nicht was
mich erwarten soll ich glaube es hat
nichts mit der deutschen currywurst zu
tun
[Musik]
das brot hat irgendwie trotzdem eine
süße die wurst ist herzhaft und das
curry verwirrt mich vollends und ich
würde ich würde es immer wieder essen so
aber es ist einfach nur von berühmt ich
glaube das wird uns heute noch häufiger
begegnen dass wir sachen einfach gar
nicht checken bei der nächste sache bin
ich ein bisschen sicherer rahmen aber
nicht irgendwelche sondern die
wahrscheinlich besten in düsseldorf okay
wir sind da takumi förster haben und ich
bin einfach gespannt was mich erwartet
[Musik]
so super dass in die serverfarmen
danke sehr schön darauf habe ich mich
sehr gefreut also ich bin sehr gespannt
wie sehen wunderbar aus dem rahmen ich
probiere zu aller erst mal das
wichtigste die brühe
[Musik]
alter schwede das ist nicht normal das
ist normal diese brühe ist so lecker
aber später durch diese brühe das ist so
die intensivste suppen grödig gegessen
und dabei ist sie trotzdem so sehr
komplex ist eine schärfe bloß eine
herzlichkeit erstmal finden seine
fertigkeiten das ist unfassbar
die rahmen nudel müssen wir natürlich
auch
wir haben obwohl sie so dünn sind noch
ein bisschen besser nicht zu weich das
ist eine direkte 10 von 10 da muss ich
weiter essen
ich höre das ist jetzt gerade so sind in
dem moment liest oder barnim uns das für
mich so auf einer höhe mit einer geilen
pizza mit dem geilen bürger also mit den
kranken scheiß ich habe
das ist selbst nicht älter ist dazu noch
garnelen mit der empfehlung von mir
unfassbar lecker nimmt auch genau diese
bestellung was soll da jetzt noch kommt
[Musik]
weil mainz herbert noch nicht genug zu
essen braucht zwischendurch einfach mal
ein kleinen snacks ohne geary und eine
ein grüner flammen drink zuallererst
zerbirst welche den grünen bringt es
riecht wie so zeigt das packaging nicht
so dass krankheiten oder gar nicht sehr
sehr krank wenn man daran richtig du
auch mal das ist sowieso ein geruch der
mann so von crazy seoul jahrmarkt
[Musik]
es schmeckt auch so dass man als kind
hast du doch so auf der kirmes auf dem
jahrmarkt hast du so kleine solo ließ
oder so diese sprühflasche hat mit dem
du deine zunge färben konnte sie haben
auch diesen unser snack dazu wir haben
eine girona mario habe ziemlich kaymer
noch auf genau das ist nämlich gerade
das coole hier steht schon so toll er
ist dass der pool und zweiter schritt an
den beiden enden ziel
war es hier bis ganz richtig mache aber
die story bleibt ist zwischen dem
plastik das wollen wir nicht essen lasst
es nur für die optik
ist dass
man sieht der reis ist lustig wie der
held schön zusammen lecker sagt ehrlich
wenn die küche also wenn die landesküche
so leckere dinge in der turbo abteilung
stehen hat dann weisst du dass krass es
ist unnormal egger aber das war noch
lange nicht das ende weiter zur nächsten
location
freddy hat mich gerade angerufen freddy
hat ein video aufgenommen wo er auch
japanische foto spots getestet hat hier
in little tokyo aber er wird es nach mir
veröffentlicht hat es aber vorher
gefällt also geht ihm nicht auf die eier
das irgendwie nach gemacht hätte es ist
es wissen reiner zufall
das wollte ich nächster sport kuchar aus
tokio hier gibt es so viel
traditionelles so zieren das wurde uns
empfohlen von den jungs kontakt also
muss gut sein wir reiten ist okay hier
sind wir also kann gar nicht so
wahnsinnig viel es quasi eine probiert
hatte einmal bin auch gespannt auf sieht
das irgendwie unterscheidet kommt es
dass ich keine
da
[Musik]
wenn das ganz besonders und zwar toro
rosso ist der fähigste wertvollste teil
vom thunfisch die kenne ich bisher nur
aus erzählungen von freunden die wir
davon vorgeschwärmt haben schaut man
sagt dass das beste kommt zum schluss
aber ich will jetzt da so gerne wissen
wie es schmeckt der fisch zu reis anteil
ist ein ganz anderer als man ihn von
vielen anderen sushi restaurants kennt
und ich habe auch gelernt dass man
eigentlich mit dem fisch nicht mit dem
reis und soja sauce rein deshalb wenn
wir hier in dieser woche sind probiert
das auch so zu machen mein erstes mal
toro ich bin gespannt
darüber
hör auf wird die sagte ehrlich brauchen
das ist so als würdest du so eine
mischung so eine perle aus butter und so
einer kräftigen grün in deinen mund
nehmen zerbeißen und sie während du
kaufst verschmilzt einfach alles also
ist verläuft wirklich in deinem kopf wir
den fisch noch mal ganz genau angucken
der vergleich mit wacken will ist
absolut gerechtfertigt weil das ist auch
alles so dieses fettgewebe was sie
dadurch zieht und der fällt hier auch
von selbst auseinander komplettes mal an
und normal ich hätte es wirklich nicht
als erstes essen sollte ich probiere es
auch mal lax nigiri auch hier wieder
mehr fisch als reis ganz dezent im
geschmack wir können tore marco
königs triebel kontrastierte perfekt
diesen beträgen fisch durch durch den
crash durch die frische das hier ist
wohl flambiert tal mit seiner teriyaki
soße obendrauf solider geist kann
schmecken
mai
das finale
[Musik]
das heißt ein abschlussfeuerwerk für
diese fischrogen die explodiert sind wow
die sucht hier vergebens nach
irgendwelchen riesig reaktion
sonst aber nicht vermissen ist auch
nicht bei hier überzeugt die qualität
tradition steht qualität
unfassbar wirklich so schlecht und diese
togo nigeria hat noch mal eine reaktion
gesehen das ist das ist nicht nicht mehr
fährt ein spot schaffe ich noch unter
mit ihm könnte beginn ist das wie ebay
und holen sondern auch ein bubble tea
auf ganz entspannt weil ich kann
wirklich nichts mehr essen dann setzen
wir uns ins auto und fahren zurück
[Musik]
so leute werden wir jetzt hier die
immermannstraße verlassen mit diesem
nicht zu süßen babbel team kann ich noch
mal kurz revue passieren ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass es so krass würdig wusste
ich wusste wirklich konnte ich mir schon
denken das ist ja geil wird heute aber
es ist nicht gespielt gewesen zu keinem
zeitpunkt wenig abgekämpft bin beim tor
wobei der brühe von den rahmen es war zu
keinem zeitpunkt over at ist einfach
nicht von dieser welt und das einfach so
auf quick so einmal schnell rüber noch
düsseldorf tag das ganze sich rein wenn
wir haben auch so krasse empfehlungen
noch bekommen vom personal von den
jeweiligen läden von den leuten die sich
hier richtig gut auskennt würde locker
noch für ein zweites video reichen wenn
ihr so ein video sehen wollen würde ich
habe wirklich bock drauf das zudrehen
und wir sind auf jeden fall beim
nächsten video wieder bis dahin macht es
gut
wenn du im urlaub so ein spot entdeckt
wie gerade den rahmen shops oder bist du
traurig und kommt vielleicht sogar
deshalb wieder in das land und hier bis
zum ohne lukas jederzeit wiederkommen
wird gerade nicht süß traurige gefühl es
ist einfach nur lästig